in the movie they have tom cruise flied  over mach 10. so maybe  can you say  what are the different speeds  accelerations feel like mach 1 2 3  or hypersonic have you ever flown  hypersonic no  um does it get how tough does it get  i'm just gonna call out the the bs of  ejecting at mach 10 just for the record  because in the movie uh there's been i  think at least one ejection that was  supersonic uh and i'll just say you know  it was not pretty but he survived um so  there would have to be some interesting  mechanisms to eject successfully at mach  10 but i'll digress on that for the  moment yeah that seemed very strange and  he just walked away from it but anyway  so you know he seemed disheveled  [Laughter]  okay it's tom cruise you know it's it's  like chuck norris or something  indestructible yeah there's an age  you